Good afternoon sir, welcome to Home World.
How can I help you today?
Hello there, I'm looking to get some living room furniture.
We have everything you need right here.
Great! I've come to the right place. Can you show me some of your sofa sets?
Right over here, sir. This is one of our most popular sofa sets.
I like the style a lot. Is that leather?
No sir, it's Naugahyde. It's a type of imitation leather.
It's very comfortable. Do you have this style in other colors?
Yes, but we don't have any here in our showroom.
You can order it in a number of different colors, though.
I have a catalogue here that you can look through.
Okay, yes, I see. Is this one beige?
Yes, it is, sir.
That looks like the exact color I want!